whoa Warner Brothers are you okay hey
yeah so we need your help what's the
deal with you lately it's like one
terrible decision after the next what do
you mean the flash is gonna fix
everything it's gonna be good it's gonna
be great all right what's your genius
idea now Harry Potter stop I didn't
finish no you had a disastrous spin-off
franchise some terrible fan fiction in a
transphobic office literally keeps
shooting herself and us in the foot feet
don't even you didn't let me finish my
idea Harry Potter HBO series the
original cast wants nothing to do with
franchise it's not gonna happen which is
why were we doing it the whole
series one book per season
you had a good run Prestige TV on HBO I
made The Sopranos hey people will watch
this that doesn't make it okay Brian Cox
is Dumbledore he'll need a job soon
Sorcerer's Stone was two and a half
hours long you really think stretching
that out into eight hours of Television
will make it better what is the first
episode just gonna be Harry chilling
with the dursleys there's more stuff in
the later book yeah I'm sure everyone's
gonna love that subplot about how all
the elf slaves love being slaves and
Hermione's just stupid for trying to
free them that's not real that's in the
books yes and it's time to move on get
out while you're still sort of ahead
maybe you're right thank you but we're
still doing it anyways I know